[Music]
magic in the moonlight is directed by
Woody Allen and stars Colin Firth and
Emma Stone what this movies about is a
magician who is sent to disprove someone
who is saying she's a psychic Colin
Firth plays this very famous magician
and since he wears a lot of makeup when
he performs a lot of people don't know
who he is when he walks around in his
everyday life
so we moonlights as a guy who goes
around and disproves people who are
saying that their spirit mediums are
psychics or they have some sort of
connection with the other world and Emma
Stone is saying that she is and so he is
sent to do just that for her and of
course you know
know Woody Allen is a bit of a hit and
miss director for me there are years
when he'll hit you really hard with the
movie like match point or like last
year's blue Jasmine which I really liked
and then there are years where you get
you Will Meet a Tall Dark Stranger and
scoop he'll make a great film that's so
well written it'll win a lot of Oscars
and then all of a sudden he'll just make
one like magic in the moonlight
unfortunately this is a movie with two
really talented actors and Colin Firth
and Emma Stone but unfortunately they're
in the middle of a story that's so
incredibly uninteresting where there's
really no tension that actually shows
itself until like 10 minutes are left in
the movie and at that point I had
already checked out from the movie
mentally there are moments in this movie
where the writing is really clever and
the writing seems fresh but there are
also moments that are incredibly cliched
that really stick out if you are
familiar with the standard romantic
comedy structure this film fits the bill
perfectly guy meets girl they don't
really get along at first because
they're opposing slowly they start to
like each other then some kind of
problem happens and then oh no we're in
the middle of a problem and they'll what
are we gonna do it's the exact same as
every romantic comedy which is very
disappointing because Woody Allen has
shown himself to be a very interesting
writer and director in the past and he
does great stuff like blue Jasmine like
match-point but this movie is so weighed
down by such a boring and cliched story
where nothing really happens that I
couldn't really get into magic in the
moonlight despite the fact that Colin
Firth and Emma Stone were really giving
these roles they're all blue Jasmine was
about a protagonist that was incredibly
rude mean to everybody and hard to live
with Colin Firth plays that exact same
type of character in this movie and it
kind of feels like Woody Allen was
almost branching off of blue
jasmin into this film which he does
sometimes he'll get stuck on like a
certain type of character or a certain
type of location like Paris and he makes
a great film like Midnight in Paris and
then he wants to do other things in
Paris or other things with similar
characters and he's doing it again of
magic in the moonlight but these
characters unfortunately just had
nothing and they were so conventional
Emma Stone is very charming she's very
beautiful she's very good as this
character there is a little bit of
mystery you're wondering like is she for
real or is she not there are moments
when the film kind of hooks you in that
regard Colin Firth is very good as this
very rude very mean and hard to live
with character however the film as a
whole is so boring and so conventional
and so filled with their standard
romantic comedy cliches that I could see
where everything was gonna go from the
get-go which really sucks cuz Woody
Allen's a very good writer
but unfortunately I think he dropped the
ball with magic in the moonlight I'm
gonna give it a see guys if you are a
fan of Woody Allen let me know what's
your favorite Woody Allen movie mine is
actually match point I find that film to
be brilliant with excellent performances
thanks as always for watching guys and I
want to give a shout out to my buddy
Troy who I met at Best Buy today after I
saw this movie he's a fan and it was
really awesome to meet you dude and to
chat with you thanks man I really
appreciate that also I want to give a
big thank you to audible.com because
they are still sponsoring my videos
these guys have been incredibly awesome
and so nice with me do please go to
audible.com slash Chris and download a
free audio book of your choice they have
an excellent selection that you can
download straight to your tablet your
iPhone your computer your mp3 player you
can listen to these things anywhere and
it's so cool how many different
celebrities have lent their voices to
this I've actually gotten emails from
you guys one person in particular
emailed me and thanked me because he
needed an audio book for his school
course but he couldn't afford it and he
was able to get it through my promotion
for free and that was so awesome I was
so incredibly pleased with that do check
out audible.com slash Chris and a big
thank you to audible for continuing to
sponsor my videos thank you so much guys
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck Emma nice
[Music]